welcome back everybody Jennifer Garner
for us give it up our next guest is an
NFL Hall of Famer and you can see him
every week on Thursday Night Football on
Prime
video it's shocking to me that you were
even able to play in this weather but
you did what was the experience like you
you know coming out to the frozen tundra
Lambo field I remember playing out here
but you do I had everything on back then
but I remember look at I scored this
touch I was like hey I turned around I'm
telling that guy don't touch me don't
touch me cuz that ground hurts uh but
honestly I don't even remember scoring
this touch that's how much the cold gets
into my
mind TNS coverage begins at 7.m Easter
tonight please welcome Tony
[Applause]
[Music]
Gonzalez
well welcome to the show so from that
video you you are not into cold you
don't like being cold oh I hate the cold
I hate it I'm a California boy I was
born and raised in California went to
Berkeley which where it was still nice
and when I got drafted to Kansas City I
was I was not prepared for like I always
called I have a condition it's called
tropical I like I like tropical weather
War but but I don't it gets to my bones
I'm just not into it oh my God I love it
so much do you really I do too
cold WEA I'm so happy it makes me so it
feels fresh like a new start oh I can't
stand it I remember when I I remember
when I went to uh Kansas City it was the
first winter I've ever felt like really
one of almost the first times I ever saw
snow and I I go out to my car and we had
this freeze and the windshield was was
frozen solid and it's got you can't see
through it so I'm like what the hell am
I going to do how do what do I do yeah
and so uh I didn't know anything about
an ice scraper I didn't know you had to
have one of those so I was like you know
what I'm SM SM I'm going to get a glass
of warm water hot water and I'm just
going to pour it on there it'll melt the
glass right it'll melt the ice right off
boom put it on there crack crack the
windshield everything I was like oh but
that was my first lesson into how to
deal with the cold weather I never
really thought about that I mean I guess
in Texas it get I there's extreme cold I
feel like and extreme heat so I like
this is Kansas City this is Kansas City
yeah it's froz that's why I don't like
heat that's I can't take my skin off you
know what I'm saying but like you can
like you can like put clothes on and
stay warmer that's not on a football
field yeah so you were in Kansas City
pre- tailor
preor well same same position right same
thing same team same team did he just
break your record kelse uh he broke my
record do you have to be bringing that
oh no no go no no because you tweeted
about it you you did something about
that's how I know yeah yeah well I'm
just Travis Kelsey you said
congratulations I say of course he's
such he's such a good dude and the whole
Taylor Swift thing now yeah is uh
becoming to I was in the airport the
other day and this 10-year-old girl
comes up to me and and I don't you know
men usually come up to me football yeah
uh and and occasionally like you know a
woman but a 10-year-old girl I was like
oh how cool I'm getting so popular that
a a t girl comes with me she goes hi is
your name Tony and I go yes it is you
know like maybe want she goes do you
know Travis Kelce I'm
like but I I think it's great that t has
done this for the NFL she's brought a
whole new
audience I I will say no that that is
true and there's a lot of swifties out
there watching now but I I will say not
because of that but I really got into
football this year like I finally I
think I just broke down because all my
friends and family are into I'm
literally an alone on an island but I am
obsessed like I'm in fantasy football
leagues like I love do you do fantasy I
do fantasy I do it with my boys My Boy
River and uh and Nico we're were in a
little league we go to a river R yeah
that's right oh my God I'm obsessed with
I almost wish I are you into football I
really like
football I really do I really like
marching bands so I
like is that not cool to admit are you
kidding me the Ohio Michigan game and
how the Ohio comes in it's cool right I
literally just lost my mic pack on that
I like no I got it Roa I'm putting it
all I'm so bendy okay um so wait talk
about Thursday Night Football what what
is the show like it's kind of crazy it's
not just football y'all y'all get fun on
this oh we do it's like a variety show
sometime I mean way we uh do it well the
the pregame show is pretty traditional
like a pregame show we get you ready for
the game what to expect what not to
expect we have some segments uh Marshon
Lynch is on there I don't know if you
guys know he is he's pretty crazy he'll
do a couple where he he'll go to like a
bar or go to a restaurant uh what else
do we do uh after the game though it's
it's really cool that's where we bring
on like the player of the game so like
Patrick Mahomes will be on Set uh we'll
we'll shower uh bazooka BRS we find how
many can you catch in 30 minutes so it's
like more fun and you're at the game so
the the energy it's electric it's just a
lot more fun I love that that seems so
much fun okay well before we do a
commercial break we got Tony's uh
special Kelly Clarkson show merch to
keep him
warm this is for you happy holiday I
love ity
holiday my
goodness and now I literally watch you
all the time I was not into football
before but now I catch everything I'm
even like the NFL plus girl you're going
to look so good can I wear this I'm
going to wear this on the set next you
should wear this you should wear
this all right everybody watch Thursday
Night Football every Thursday starting
at 700 p.m. Eastern only on Prime
[Music]
video
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home